قد يكون موسم الإنفلونزا القادم
شديدًا بشكل خاص ،
هذا هو التحذير من خبراء الصحة
الذين يقولون إنه خلال الوباء
لم تكن هناك وفيات تقريبًا بسبب الأنفلونزا
مقارنة بالسنوات السابقة ،
حيث لم يشهد العالم أي موسم للإنفلونزا ولم
أشاهد سوى القليل جدًا من انتشار الأنفلونزا
الأخرى.  فيروسات الجهاز التنفسي أيضًا
وفقًا للخبراء ، يمكن أن
تكون الأسباب هي التدابير المتخذة ضد covid19
أو أن الفيروس التاجي قد تدخل
في مسار
الأنفلونزا المعتاد.ريتشارد ويب بواسطة أخصائي الأنفلونزا في
مستشفى سانت جود لأبحاث الأطفال في ممفيس
يعتقد أنه عندما تعود الأنفلونزا من
المحتمل في خريف هذا
العام  سيكون التأثير أكبر لأن
مناعتنا قد تضاءلت قليلاً ،
ويقول webby إن موسم الإنفلونزا القادم قد
يكون أسوأ ما شهدناه على الإطلاق
من حيث الإنفلونزا ، نحن حقًا في
منطقة مجهولة ، وهناك
احتمال أن يعود
الأمر بقليل  أكثر قليلاً
مما رأيناه على مدى السنوات القليلة
الماضية ،
فإن النظرية هي أننا نخلع الأقنعة
ونعود إلى المدرسة  اعمل على الخروج إلى
المطاعم والاختلاط بالآخرين كما اعتدنا ،
سنتعرض لفيروسات الجهاز التنفسي الأخرى
مرة أخرى ،
يعترف الخبراء بأن نشاط الإنفلونزا
مستحيل التنبؤ به ، لكن ويبي
يوصيك بالحصول على لقاح الإنفلونزا عندما
يكون متاحًا
وممارسة النظافة الشخصية
وغسل اليدين  تغطية العطس
مرة أخرى يبدو أنها تعمل بشكل جيد
ضد جميع فيروسات الجهاز التنفسي
بما في ذلك الأنفلونزا
في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم أنا ستيف
نانوس